This is an oversimplification, but here's
how a movie gets made: actors film scenes
by saying their lines, and then the director
and editors assemble a cut using the best
takes of each scene.
Sometimes a messed up take ends up in the
final film because it still works with the
story, but other times, bloopers just have
no business being anywhere near the movie.
Here are some bloopers and outtakes from movies
that never made it into the final cut for
some very easily understandable reasons.
Suicide Squad
In director David Ayer's manic, cartoonish
villain-o-rama Suicide Squad, the usually
heroic Will Smith plays very much against
type as Deadshot, a character who's both a
hitman and an expert sharpshooter.
In other words, he's someone who knows his
guns.
So he would never do this:
"Ahhh!"
"You guys are safe."
A shot of Will Smith bungling the process
of loading a gun might make a funny moment
in a different film, but it never would have
worked for the character named after his ability
to shoot things.
Bad Moms
NFL defenseman J.J.
Watt has started making the move into showbiz,
and he's a pretty funny guy who usually seems
as comfortable onscreen as he does smashing
into other behemoths on the gridiron.
In Bad Moms, he plays a soccer coach who bears
some of the brunt of Mila Kunis' character's
rage—and in one take, she so convincingly
bursts into Watt's office that the otherwise
macho dude seems genuinely scared.
"Gwendolyn made me do it!"
"What the f--- did you say?!"
"You kicked the s--- out of that door!"
Unfortunately, the blooper had to be cut.
You can't have your movie's tough guy screaming
like one of the kids he coaches.
That Awkward Moment
This millennial comedy is all about the cringe-inducing
moments we all seem to put ourselves through.
But the most awkward moment in the movie occurs
in a blooper when just about every framed
poster in a conference room scene comes loose
and falls down.
"Hah!"
It wasn't planned, and as fittingly awkward
as it may have been, it kind of ruins a movie's
credibility if the entire set starts falling
apart onscreen.
Scandal
Most modern Americans carry their smartphone
with them wherever they go.
Even actors actively working on a set carry
their phones around with them—out of view
of the camera and with the ringer turned off,
of course.
Well, they're supposed to turn the ringer
off.
While shooting a scene for Scandal, Guillermo
Diaz gets a bit embarrassed when he's interrupted
by the sound of his own phone going off.
"We knew this was coming, Liv."
"Sorry, lemme check my text really quick!"
Red Eye
In Red Eye, Cillian Murphy plays a psycho
terrorizing a woman on a plane.
It's a tense, pulse-pounding, exhausting thriller
with few light-hearted moments, and you get
the real sense that Cillian's character is
so crazy he can't be stopped.
You tell the flight attendant and your dad
dies."
That means that this charming bit with a little
girl threatening to beat up Murphy just didn't
fit in.
"Is that guy bugging you?
Because I can take him out in a New York Minute."
The girl is still in the final film, but her
apparently improvised line is nowhere to be
seen.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!